We're moving again. We hopped on a flight to Connecticut
to go house hunting for the next few days,
and even though Texas was fun,
it's just not where we wanna be long term.
We want a slower life, being in a more quiet area,
having more space, being able to get some chickens and start gardening.
But also being closer to a bigger city for all the work that we do.
And also being closer to Europe because my parents live out there.
We've looked at six houses so far and have a favorite house.
This one wasn't it.
Even though lucky loved all the frogs that were on the property.
Even though the view was stunning,
this felt more like a vacation rental to us.
So we decided to take a break and grab some lunch
before heading over to the second house that we wanted to see.
Since we're so picky with our houses,
we knew we were gonna buy a house that we'd have to renovate anyways,
so we're looking for a good layout,
but also just that feeling of knowing that this is our home.
House was so cute. I absolutely love the indoor pool.
There was plenty of space to garden in the back
and put in a basketball court
since that's one of Lucky's priorities.
I love a historical home. Even though I adored this house,
we were just too tall to make this work.
We have a few more houses to see.
Before making our decision